comment est-ce que ça se passe le
remboursement d'un billet sncf et
spécialement tgv puisque les usagers
prennent un majorité du temps le tgv
pour rejoindre leur famille au rang des
fêtes
est ce qu'on constate c'est une grosse
cacophonie alors ce soit au niveau de la
sncf son envol l'organisation ou de
certains trains qui sont supprimées
annoncé supprimer qui finalement sont à
quai alors qu'est ce que vous vous
conseiller et comment est-ce qu'on se
fait rembourser un billet sncf pour la
france alors il ya trois cas de figure
le premier cas de figure votre train est
à quai on vous l'a annoncé comme étant
là vous pouvez monter dedans donc zéro
problème le deuxième cas de figure c'est
des gens qui étaient sur un train à une
heure donnée et on a transféré
l'ensemble du train à une autre heure
ceux là ont été avertis ça concerne en
gros 10 à 15 % des passagers
donc pour cela pas de problème sauf ceux
qui décideraient de ne pas partir parce
que le nouvel horaire ne leur convient
pas il peut y avoir des différences de
plusieurs heures et donc cela il faut
qu'ils annulent leurs billets sur
internet et se feront rembourser aux à
plus tard justement comment ils sont
remboursés service après-vente de la
sncf com com en temps normal sauf que le
service après vente vous vous doutez va
être submergés et qu' il y aura
probablement plusieurs semaines avant
que les remboursements des lieux
troisième cas de figure vous faites
partie
malheureusement des entre 40 et 30 % de
passagers qui n'ont pas de train et qui
ont atteint billets donc ce week-end on
estimait qu'il y avait 2 190 mille
personnes en gros qui avait habillé pour
un tram et qui n'avait pas de trains les
cff le recommande d'essayer de faire un
échange qu'il doit faire eux-mêmes et
l'échangent justement j'ai grandi là
dessus l'échangé été annoncée par la
sncf où il n'y aurait pas de frais alors
c'est là où est la complication
c'est que quand les gens vont sur
internet et qui choisissent un autre
train évidemment le train quitte choisi
ce n'est pas au même prix que celui
qu'ils avaient initialement
c'est là vous et toute la subtilité de
la chose il faut aller jusqu'au bout du
processus pour se rendre compte que la
sncf fait une remise sur la différence
de prix si vous êtes en cours de
processus vous voyez un train 110 euros
on vous dit oui voilà c'est 110 euros
alors que vous avez un billet à 70 vous
pensez que vous avez 40 euros à payer si
vous allez au bout du processus
à ce moment là vous ne paierez pas la
différence
mais il ya plein de cas de figure où les
gens ne peuvent pas échangé le billet et
c'est là où et toute la complication
les gens qui peuvent changer de billets
c'est par exemple les gens qui ont un
billet aller retour
quand vous avez consommé l'aller vous
pouvez pas changer le retour ou quand
vous n'avez pas consommer l'aller vous
pouvez pas quand je le change et leur
tour peuvent on peut pas faire les deux
et puis deuxième chose très importante
c'est que pour une raison qu'on découvre
en fait les quand vous avez un billet à
une date donnée par exemple un billet
pour demain avec un retour mardi à cause
de la grèce je décide de décaler d'une
semaine
eh ben les changes n'est pas possible
parce que vous êtes au delà de la date
de retour
c'est à dire que si vous avez votre
retour était prévu pour mardi vous ne
pouvez pas échanger votre billet pour le
mercredi d'après et le mardi d'après
donc ça c'est des gens qui sont obligés
de racheter un billet le porte parole de
la sncf a assuré que le remboursement se
ferait sur le billet le plus cher donc
sur le nouveau billet acheté un petit
peu compliqué quand même un peu
compliqué je suis désolé mais que je dis
vous avez la cilam on se rend compte de
toutes les carences du système digital
de la sncf
à cause de ces événements et on se rend
compte que le premier site de e-commerce
en france est enfin en fait un colosse
aux pieds d'argile
c'est à dire que tout le système de la
digital de la sncm repose sur une des
choses tellement compliqués qu'ils
peuvent probablement marché à peu près
bien en temps normal mais qui implose
dans les périodes de crise comme en ce
moment